[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SINGING] You called me
out of darkness into light.
The power of Satan is broken.
I'm free.
I have new light.
I'll shout you're praises.
How great you are.
You're awesome presence
lives inside my heart.
You're a great
and marvelous God.
You called me out.
You called me out from
darkness into light.
The power of Satan is broken.
I'm free.
I have new light.
I'll shout your praises.
How great you are.
Your awesome presence
lives inside my heart.
You're a great
and marvelous God.
Great.
Great and marvelous God.
Good afternoon.
Welcome to this MLK luncheon.
It's our pleasure to
sing for you today.
We're the MIT gospel choir.
We're just a group
of students who
love to sing, and sing about
God and his love for us.
So if you could just
please take a seat,
this kind of marks the
beginning of the program.
We have one more
selection for you.
So please enjoy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SINGING] Great Jehovah,
you are beautiful.
And we give you glory.
Great Jehovah,
you are beautiful.
And we give you glory.
Glory, glory to the
lamb, to the lamb.
He's the kingdom and the
power, and the glory forever.
Forever to the
lamb, to the lamb.
He's the kingdom, and the
power, and the glory forever.
Forever, to the
lamb, to the lamb.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.